hey wisecrack Jared again and today
we're talking about one of the best
superhero movies in years Logan Logan is
radically different from other superhero
movies and especially other x-men movies
that's because well it's not really a
superhero movie at all this fresh
approach to the franchise puts forward a
surprising message about the world's
relationship to nature and even a meta
commentary on the Marvel Cinematic
Universe that you might have missed
welcome to this wisecrack edition on the
philosophy of Logan and you guessed it
spoilers ahead but first a quick recap
Logan is the heart-tugging tail of
Wolverine Charles Xavier and their
refugee kid Laura evading cyborg child
predators out to weaponize mutant see it
takes place in a future where mutinous
have become nearly extinct and Logan
drives an uber to save enough money to
escape from the law with Charles before
we can dive into the philosophy we have
to understand what the movie is it's a
Western and not just because it's sandy
and takes place in you know the West
according to sociologist Will Wright in
his book six guns in society the classic
Western follows a pretty standard
structure our hero often a man from the
wild enters a social group gets dragged
into a conflict to protect his new
civilized friends before finally saving
the day and usually becoming a part of
this new group to grasp Logan's Western
roots pay attention to be from the wild
part and I found you you were pursuing a
career as a cage fighter I gave you
throughout all the x-men movies both
good and so bad we're reminded of
Wolverines animal nature people don't
change
Logan doesn't really find a new group of
friends but finds a family with Laura
and Charles and later with the other
transition kids the film makes a point
to juxtapose the civilized love of his
friends with his innate wild nature
there's Logan's violence his resilience
to pick up Laura in the first place not
available call a cab he's swearing out
of my car and we even get some
distinctly animal-like noises while
Logan is sleeping
as an ode to all this we see Charles and
Laura watching a classic Western in
their hotel room shame in the film our
gun-slinging hero shane emerges from the
wild makes friends with some
homesteaders and saves them from a
cattle baron shane realizes his violent
ways have no place in society and rides
back into the woods perhaps to die
depending on who you ask
replace homesteaders with family and
cattle baron with mega-corporation and
you've got Logan in a nutshell a very
deliberate nutshell but as much as Logan
is a Western like Shane it's also a post
Western in the tradition of movies like
Clint Eastwood's Unforgiven a post
Western discards the tired black and
white binaries between good and evil it
explores what happens when these men of
the Wild West returned to a drastically
different world one that has moved past
them they are in short about living in
the end of an era
Charles the world is not the same as it
was just as a post Western might feature
a Cowboys violent nature as a relic of
the pre-industrial era you want to come
along anybody it used to be but Logan
features Wolverine as a relic from the
age of mutants he liked a post Western
hero has to grapple with what it means
to be living in a new world a world
where mutants are nearly extinct the
only evidence of Logan's former world is
an x-men comic books with that in mind
we can start to understand what Logan is
trying to say about nature all we need
is a little help from a 500 year old
English legal practice seriously let me
explain nature as a theme is everywhere
in Logan Charles tends to a garden Logan
wants to escape the world and live on
the open seas and Charles compares Laura
to wildlife and by the way Laura sport
cause of the obvious
jebadiah is that a fact nature is also
juxtaposed with technology natural
mutants are set up against cyborgs twice
were reminded that Laura isn't natural
she's not a natural [ __ ] up like she's a
business mistake are indeed going bad
unlike you she isn't pure she wasn't
made by Nature the family farm is pinned
up against a giant agricultural company
pumping corn syrup into our bodies and
Charles laments being pharmaceutically
castrated by all the drugs he's taking I
guess you prefer me pharmaceutical
castrated rambling on like a lunatic and
Logan a natural mutant is being killed
by his artificial adamantium skeleton
there's a specific historical
development that embodies the struggle
and could teach us a bit about how our
world and Logan's works
it's called enclosure enclosure was an
English practice of taking communal land
free for anyone's use and enclosing it
into private farms cutting it off from
the public the underlying logic is take
something open unpredictable imperfect
and uncontrollable and order it with
rules and law to the detriment of the
public in the West vast open swathes of
land were free for animals to graze in
before the advent of barbed wire
encouraged farmers to fence them in to
the detriment of these free spaces
enclosure not only motivates the
conflict in Shane and expect to find any
fences around here but all the themes in
Logans seem designed to reflect it too
in Shane a group of homesteaders Duke it
out with a cattle baron to see who has
the right to order the West
that's Ryker spread all that over there
it's the whole world belongs to here
whether that order is for everyday
people God didn't make all this country
just
one man like Ryker or for the cattle
Baron's moneyed interests in Logan the
Munson's Duke it out with transition
over the same issue of land a
conversation about eminent domain
becomes very enclosure s as public water
becomes unavailable to the Munson's who
wouldn't sell they tried eminent domain
that's wrong with home and Logan yearns
to be on the open ocean a place free of
borders and the creeping encroachment of
corporate enclosure but this focus on
enclosure takes on another meaning as
Logan and Charles Duke it out with
transition to see who has the right to
order the future of mutant sea sea
conflicts of enclosure are not
necessarily of open space but of well
everything as writer Raul Martinez notes
enclosure has moved beyond territories
extending the reach of markets into
every corner of our lives in what some
have dubbed an enclosure of the mind
intellectual property rights are being
extended to include facets of life that
were once considered uncommon a file
algorithms symbols words ideas seeds and
even human genes in other words if
pythagoras were alive today somebody
would have patented his theorems and
created some kind of triangle based
startup ideas which once freely
contributed to society our patents and
commodities to be traded gene sequences
freely available in nature are becoming
the intellectual property of
pharmaceutical companies transition has
turned the genetic information of
Wolverine and countless other mutants
into patents and R&D projects it's not
just that companies are making a profit
off someone else's genes the core logic
of enclosure is turn any semblance of
the Commons which is unmanageable and
potentially dangerous and turn it into
something manageable but though was not
a mutant kind it's a controller when it
comes to the enclosure of genetic
material the naturally occurring version
becomes a liability to the corporate
interest seeking to profit off their own
artificial version random mucousy went
away
my bobtail I'm next to death groaning it
was in your honor Isis
hence the Wild West of
naturally-occurring mutants must end
just as Shane marks the end of the
lawless open land
Logan marks the end of organic mutant
sea mutant powers are fine so long as
they are in the hands of a corporation
that allegedly has everything under
control
meanwhile events like Charles seizures
become proof that natural butan sea is
dangerous and uncontrollable I'm sorry
enclosure creates a world where safe and
business-friendly are walled off from
the unwieldy wild and anything outside
these borders must slowly be
incorporated into it the logic of
borders both real and metaphorical are
not lost on Logan the beginning of the
film shows Logan navigating between the
United States and Mexico the border
operates to let American businessman and
partygoers in and out in the service of
business while presumably keeping
everything else out the film's ending
when Laura and her friends escape to
Canada doesn't give us a physical border
but the open expanses of the Canadian
wilderness this creeping control of
business into all aspects of life frames
Logan's eternal struggle a man who
drives around people for money Logan
only initially risks his life for Laura
for a fat stack of cash meanwhile
Charles serves as a counterpoint all of
that gardening stuff becomes a
compelling metaphor for Logan
Charles nurtures people out of
compassion and encourages Logan to care
for Laura regardless of money she's your
daughter
this nurturing attitude is juxtaposed
with Pierce who reminds Caliban
necessary that people don't really
change and dr. Rice who prefers
artificial design over nature to come
much younger age is simply design it
from scratch the real battle for Laura
is a battle for her soul will she be
like Logan a man who can't break the
mold or can she avoid his mistakes by
living with a nurturing family Logan
eventually seems to side with Charles
opting to refuse the money from Laura
and give up his life Logan's nemesis x24
is a soulless version of himself a
compelling reminder of what he could
have been a mindless mercenary at the
beck and call of his corporate masters
in the final showdown with the Reavers
we get a
Captain Planet moment when all the kids
use elemental forces ice electricity and
grass to kill a river laura gives a
eulogy for the fallen logan reciting the
words from shane everything was alright
I'm gonna bud now you run on home to
your mother and tell her tell her
everything's alright no I didn't want
guns in the back in Shane these words
justify his retreat back into nature
while his violent ways saved the
homesteaders they can never exist
alongside the town they hope to build
devoid of violence Shane can't break the
mold and neither can Logan man has to be
what it is Jimmy can't break them you
can't break tomorrow Laura's words
remind us that Logan's violence was
incompatible with the future Charles had
hoped for Laura
but his violence also enabled them to
build that better future free from
violence and the interference of people
like transited it's the end of an era
for the x-men and Logan's sacrifice
established a new world for his daughter
so while Logan shows a triumph over the
logic of enclosure what if it's also
served to be a sly commentary on the
state of comic book movies let's not
forget that westerns were Hollywood's
bread and butter for many years similar
to how superhero movies are today if we
want to reframe nature versus business
to artistry versus business the struggle
of Logan as a character reflects the
battle over the soul of Wolverine in the
ruthless profiteering world of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and they're
pissing contest with Fox who owns the
x-men rights nothing is sacred Marvel
allegedly canceled Fantastic Four comics
to deprive Fox of source material Fox
will sue the hell out of Marvel if any
of their movies dare say the word mutant
and entire movies are made just to that
box Sony or Marvel can retain the rights
to certain franchises and should the
x-men ever get reacquired by the MCU it
would have to fit the mold so to speak
and adhere to whatever tonal stylistic
choices Marvel executives have made
while adapting itself to play nice with
their decided on continuity all for the
sake of ticket sales in a sense the
freely interpretable source material of
the x-men would be enclosed by the MCU
and maybe that's why Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine really had to die does not box
or Marvel or anyone else from getting
their grubby little hands on what may be
one of the best depictions of a
superhero ever made thanks a lot for
watching wisecrack peace and wisecrack
thanks so much for watching if you can't
get enough pop-culture criticism be sure
to check out our buddy Mike Rugnetta at
the PBS idea channel whether you're
wondering about the origins of the
hoodie or worried we might all be
cyborgs Mike's got your back he really
knows his stuff and like us he uses
literature philosophy history and
science to glean insight into everything
so check out Mike at the PBS idea
channel tell him I said what's up and be
sure to subscribe while you're there and
if you like what we do and want to help
us do more consider becoming a patron
you'll get access to our growing library
of patron only content including my
latest video on daddy issues in
guardians of the galaxy part 2 my rant
on Suicide Squad and our 8-bit
philosophy episode on VR porn and
there's more patron only stuff coming
like early access videos quick takes and
more so check out our patreon page by
clicking here or the link in the
description below that's all for now
wisecrack don't forget to subscribe
peace
you